the rate of female veteran suicides is
250 percent higher than it is for
civilian women how are we helping female
veterans in particular one of the issues
that we have identified this is VA
research that there is no faster
demographic group in in the issue of
veteran suicides than women veterans and
so VA has established specific women's
health centers to try to give care in a
setting that is respectful of the way
that they want to be treated
is that new that is this is a new effort
going on and so what we've seen is those
women that get care in the VA have seen
a decrease in their suicide rate where
women veterans who get care outside the
VA or maybe aren't getting care just
choose not to use the VA have seen close
to a hundred percent increase in suicide
over the last fourteen years I was
thinking about the Department of
Veterans Affairs motto mmm-hmm to care
for him who shall have borne the battle
and for his widow and his orphan mm-hmm
that's engraved on every plaque outside
the VA comes from Abraham Lincoln yes
right that was a hundred and fifty years
ago and Lincoln's second inaugural
address a month before the Civil War
ended and of course that is history and
we can't change Lincoln's words but I
can tell you that I believe that if
President Lincoln were alive today he
would do what we say is that our mission
in the Department of Veteran Affairs and
frankly for the country is to care for
those that have borne the battle because
today as you know the fastest growing
demographic in the military are women
and women are serving in almost every
capacity right now and so this is an
organization in the Department of
Veteran Affairs that's committed to
serving all of those who serve and it's
an inclusive organization do you believe
the VA does enough to recognize the
needs of female veterans I don't I think
that we are dealing with years and years
of treating our veterans as if they were
all male and now of course this is an
organization that needs to modernize and
become much more sensitive in many ways
not only to women but to all issues
related to diversity of course the
military is an organization that is in
many ways colorblind religion blind and
now increasingly should be gender blind
that's one of the great things about the
military yeah is that it that it treats
almost everybody the same or at least
aims to do that yes yes yes we need to
as a country